terrible accident d'autocar près de
perpignan six personnes dont deux femmes
et un enfant ont été tuées et une
trentaine d'autres blessés un drame dû à
la rupture des frênes un camion semi
remorque que l'autocar a heurté de plein
fouet liban après neuf ans de guerre
cinquante mille morts et cent cinquante
mille blessés première grande
manifestation pacifique à beyrouth et
dans d'autres grandes villes du monde
invitée l'antenne de midi trois
représentants des communautés
chrétiennes
bruges est chiite deux français sur
trois s'adonne au jardinage pour un
chiffre d'affaires de 17 milliards de
nos francs
voltaire doit être content qu'ils
disaient il faut savoir cultiver notre
jardin santé les dix jours pour la forme
aujourd'hui dernier épisode du
feuilleton dont sept de 12h
martin alain aragneau italie dans son
pays au touquet pour nous parler en
direct des bienfaits de la
thalassothérapie
le suicide est la dernière pièce du
soviétique nicolaï erdman mise en scène
au théâtre national de l'odéon par jean
pierre vincent contrairement à son titre
cette oeuvre est hilarante et très
politique
parmi les interprètes françois chaumette
que nous retrouverons dans la deuxième
partie de cette édition
permettez-moi d'abord de vous dire
bonjour il doit forcément existait une
loi des séries en tout cas l'actualité
nous en pour porte la preuve ce matin
avec cette succession d'accidents
d'autocar
les deux premiers ont eu lieu en espagne
en l'espace de trois heures à quelques
kilomètres de madrid un autocar
transportant des supporters de l'équipe
du fc barcelone quitte la route a pas
une fausse manoeuvre
cinq personnes sont tuées et une
trentaine d'autres blessées dans l'île
de majorque aux baléares un autocar
déraper s'écrase dans un torrent 20
mètres plus bas
neuf touristes britanniques sont tuées
et 37 autres blessées
cette nuit à quelques kilomètres de la
frontière du perthus
un autocar de pèlerins espagnols heurte
de plein fouet un semi-remorque renversé
en travers de la route
bilan six morts et une trentaine de
blessés patrice pollet
l'accident s'est produit au boulou à 4
km de la frontière
un car de touristes espagnols a percuté
de plein fouet un camion portugais
couché sur l'autoroute à bord du car 53
pèlerins espagnols la plupart d'entre
eux dorment
il est une heure du matin dans la nuit
le kafil dans la descente qui l'emmène
vers perpignan
de l'autre côté sur la voie montante
direction l'espagne
le camion portugais de 38 tonnes est en
panne sèche son chauffeur est parti
chercher du carburant son frein à main
serré mais pas pour longtemps
amène droite dirige sur l'espagne et en
gasoil gasoil il a laissé le camion en
stationnement sommes prêts le camion a
reculé
il a traversé l'autoroute heures les
glissières et il s'est couché en travers
de l'autoroute à l'autre 16 et le calque
arrivé d'espagne heures et les surprises
et ans d'écart à mendoza long de 20
mètres couché en travers de l'autoroute
le camion est invisible dans la nuit le
quart percuté la remorque de plein fouet
de la carcasse de l'autocar les
sauveteurs retirons six morts dont un
enfant et 32 blessés cet accident aurait
pu être évité selon les enquêteurs
en plus du frein à main il aurait suffi
aux chauffeurs de placer des cales sous
les roues arrière du véhicule une
certaine partie de la gauche syndicale
et politique nommé tâche ne ménage pas
ses critiques de la politique de rigueur
préconisée par jacques delors je veux
dire que le parti communiste et la cgt
manifeste ouvertement leur opposition au
gouvernement
en s'en prenant à la personne du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
monsieur marché qui hier disait en
substance c'est pas de la rigueur mais
de l'austérité et cela ne correspond pas
à nos accords puis monsieur henri
krasucki qui hier soir à nice évoquant
le budget annoncé pour 85 à utiliser
l'expression de mazo ministre
de l'économie et des finances donné
quelques indications sur le prochain
budget et elles sont particulièrement
préoccupantes
ce qui ce qui existe actuellement va de
plus en plus dans le sens d'une
austérité on l'appelle rigueur mais ça
devient vraiment de l'austérité et ceux
qui s'annonce pour l'année prochaine est
suffisamment inquiétant pour que nous
disions aux travailleurs ça ça n'est pas
possible parce que c'est un budget maso
un coupes sombres dans les effectifs
dont les équipements dans donc dans les
travaux ça va avec conséquences pour
l'emploi pour le niveau de vie ça ne
concerne pas que les travailleurs des
services publics s'intéressent
l'ensemble des travailleurs de ce pays
il est temps de dire alerte et de s'en
occuper dès maintenant les prévisions de
gaz de france ne sont pas bonnes en 84
l'établissement public affichait un
déficit possible de 4 milliards de
francs
ce n'est pas rien et cela risque de
gêner singulièrement l'objectif de
restauration des grands équilibres du
pays comme nous le dit maintenant
laurent carenzo après de déficit
consécutif de 2 milliards et demi de
francs 82 et 83 gaz de france pourrait
se retrouver avec un nouveau trou de 4
milliards cette année de causes
essentielles à cette sombre perspective
d'abord le dollar les prévisions
budgétaires de gaz de france tablait sur
un dollar à 750 alors qu'il tourne
régulièrement depuis quelques mois
autour de 8 rentrant coût de la facture
dollars 2 milliards et demi de fond sur
l'année ensuite le gaz algérien lors de
l'accord avec l'algérie il était prévu
que le surcoût de 20 % provenant de ce
contrat de coopération serait
intégralement couverts par l'état hélas
rigueur oblige le gouvernement ne veut
plus éponger cette ardoise ou de la
facture gaz algérien un milliard et demi
de francs
dans ces conditions la seule solution
pour gaz de france c'est l'augmentation
des tarifs
mais là aussi la rigueur guette et
jacques delors après avoir accordé une
hausse de 5 et demi pour cent en février
freine des quatre fers pour une nouvelle
augmentation
or pour équilibrer ses comptes gaz de
france devrait bénéficier d'un coup de
pouce de -8 et demi pour cent de rudes
négociations sont donc à prévoir
malgré ces inquiétudes pourtant gaz de
france se porte plutôt bien ses ventes
augmenter de 15% depuis l'automne et ses
fournitures à l'industrie de 20%
un paradoxe de plus dans le paysage
économique français
pas encore de nouveau bulletin de santé
du premier ministre toujours ici
toujours hospitalisé à l'hôpital du val
de grâce à paris les médecins qui le
traite ont pratiqué ce matin une
fibroscopie du poumon intervention acier
douloureuse d'ailleurs l'état de santé
du premier ministre n'a pas justifié
toutefois l'intérim puisque pierre
mauroy traite les dossiers avec ses
collaborateurs depuis sa chambre il
devrait être de retour à l'hôtel
matignon à partir de mercredi prochain 9
ans de guerre cinquante mille morts et
cent cinquante mille blessés voilà le
triste bilan de la guerre fratricide du
liban pour la première fois depuis le
début de cette guerre
un certain nombre d'hommes et de femmes
appartenant aux trois communautés du
pays ont décidé d'une grande
manifestation pour la paix au liban
manifestations qui se dérouleront à
paris à new york à san francisco mais
aussi à beyrouth à beyrouth où cette
nuit ont eu lieu de nouveaux
affrontements entre l'armée et les
milices chiites faisant huit morts
une capitale dans les soubresauts de la
guerre et un gouvernement qui ne
parvient pas à se réunir
c'est donc dans ces conditions que va se
dérouler la manifestation pour la paix
sur la ligne du musée c'est un endroit
dont nous vous avons souvent parlé dans
nos différentes éditions et qui est
certainement le plus dangereux de
beyrouth comme van hulle expliquer
maintenant patrick sacco est donc ce
passage du musée le voici
il s'appelle ainsi à cause du musée de
beyrouth qui est situé à l'entrée même
de l'un venu ce musée bien entendu est
fermé les gendarmes libanais avec leurs
bérets rouges sont censés faire le
tampon entre les belligérants et assurer
une certaine sécurité aux libanais de
toutes confessions qui devrait passer
d'un secteur à l'autre
ici ils vont tenter de confisquer le
revolver d'un automobiliste
mais après présentation papier
abandonneront leurs projets
ce passage du musée pour tous les bleus
les beyrouthins est le grand sujet de
conversation les embouteillages ils sont
interminables
il n'est pas rare d'y passer six ou sept
heures pour parcourir 800 m si l'on est
en voiture ou en camion
alors la plupart des beyrouth après
faire passer à pied les hommes
d'affaires qui ont sont souvent obligés
maintenant d'avoir un bureau à l'est et
à l'ouest viennent signer leur courrier
ou régler leurs comptes au passage même
pour gagner du temps et l'on assiste à
des scènes qui serait cocasse si cela ne
signifiait pas pour les beyrouthins le
risque est toujours présent de voir des
obus tombé sur ce passage où une
fusillade se déclenchait alors patricia
costume il avait matérialisé ces images
que l'on voit donc du musée sur une
carte qui posé sur un chevalet alors
voilà le l'avenue thierry thiès passage
du musée c'est la seule voie d'accès
entre la zone chrétienne et la zone
musulmane au dessus de ce passage est en
dessous c'est la ligne de démarcation la
ligne de front où l'on se bat absolument
à jour et nuit vient patricia nous avons
donc invité trois personnes trois
représentants des trois communautés du
liban madame dominique et des qui est à
ma droite et qui est maronite monsieur
arabe obala qui est chiite et madame
hamel mac à rennes qui est une ruse
alors la première question que je vais
poser c'est à madame dominique eddé vous
êtes donc maronite quel est pour vous
l'objectif de ce rassemblement pour la
paix
ce rassemblement pour la paix qui est à
l'initiative d'un grand nombre de gens
qui sont eux mêmes en dehors de tout
parti ou de toutes tendances politiques
précises qui ont certes leur idée est un
mouvement qui a été totalement spontanée
pour manifester au monde entier et au
liban en particulier ceux qu'on a
tendance à oublier à savoir une volonté
de vivre ensemble
cette volonté de vivre ensemble on peut
et à juste titre en douter parfois le
liban a été pendant huit ans l'objet des
pires atrocités et des pires tragédies
et il peut paraître naïf aujourd'hui de
croire qu'une manifestation comme
celle-ci peut venir contredire cet état
de fait mais à mon sens elle est très
importante parce que précisément
elle vient à contre courant de toutes
les idées reçues et souvent fausses au
sujet de la population libanaise
patricia cost vous vous êtes druzes et
vous revenez de beyrouth alors dans quel
état d'esprit se prépare cette
manifestation si tous d'avoir dans dans
un état d'épuisement total passé neuf
ans de guerre
les gens sont usés jusqu'aux bouts
atteint même dans l'oeuf dans neuf
volonté de survie et ils sont surtout
désespérés parce que la guerre continue
et elle continue son sans aucune
perspective
et c'est de la paix et que ce n'est plus
un choix mais une élève des actifs
une exigence que des hommes politiques
parce que la guerre nous applique la
violence n'ont entraîné que la violence
et que ça ne pouvait mener qu'à
l'impasse est une exigence une haine
évidemment parce que les gens n'en
peuvent plus bien monsieur monsieur bah
là vous vous êtes le représentant de la
communauté chiite est ce que selon vous
on peut déplacer on peut dépasser à
beyrouth et au liban en général le
problème de la confessionnalité cette
manifestation a pour objectif de
dépasser soin de la fonctionnalité et je
voudrais adresser d'abord quelque chose
ici certes nous sommes appartenant
chacun une communauté mais nous sommes
d'abord libanais avant d'être avant
d'apporter un quelconque communauté
monsieur bah là j'aurais simplement vous
faire référence à l'actualité qui est en
train de en train de se faire puisque
monsieur nabih berry aurait accepté un
compromis pour une solution pour que le
gouvernement puisse se réunir vous savez
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure il était
impossible de trouver un compromis il
semblerait qu'il soit en train de se
faire en voie de règlement tout cas nous
n'avons aucune confirmation officielle
sion que des renseignements ceux-ci
montrer qu'on vaut bien dépasser tous
ces problèmes du confessionnalisme et
que bon il est un fait que au liban le
professeur zhu pets pas existé et
existent toujours et que par voie de
conséquence la haine s'est installé dans
90 dans de nombreux foyers au liban mais
ceci n'empêche qu'il existe toujours une
importante potentialités de solidarité
de coexistence fraternelles entre deux
libanais et nous souhaitons que cette
que cette manifestation aura lieu
tantôt liban qu'à l'étranger soit le
porte toute la
le porte voix de cet espoir que nous
nous laissons nous tous et si vous
pensez que 50 mineurs ce n'est pas une
cicatrice trop grande qui empêche toute
réconciliation
la reconstitution est toujours possible
ce n'est pas au nombre de nos forêts
sont arrêtées là est la médée voudrait
dire un dernier mot permettez je
voudrais ajouter un mot nous souhaitons
beaucoup est très nombreux demain pour
plusieurs raisons est la plus importante
c'est que les gens qui demain d'est et
d'ouest vont se retrouver sur cette
ligne de démarcation que nous avons vu
tout à l'heure vont prendre des risques
énormes et nous savons quels risques et
nous voulons que chérif qui sont pris
aujourd'hui soit soutenue de la manière
la plus la plus importante la plus grave
et la plus sérieuse possible à
l'étranger nous tous libanais comme
responsable de la manifestation de
beyrouth main mesdames messieurs merci
d'avoir choisi en 2010 pour montrer
votre volonté d'une réconciliation entre
les communautés du libre avant de passer
la parole à brigitte simonetta pour les
prévisions météo je voudrais maintenant
vous donner ces deux informations tout
d'abord cet attentat à l'explosif contre
les locaux d'un concessionnaire renault
à saint sébastien ce matin l'attentât
n'était toujours pas revendiqué
et puis en italie où une cinquantaine de
personnes dont le directeur de
l'aéroport ont été arrêtés pour trafic
de drogue
la personnalité en question était
responsable de l'aviation civile en
calabre et faisait partie d'une bande de
trafiquants de drogue qui utilisaient
les aéroports du sud de l'italie pour
passer d'importantes quantités de
stupéfiants
voilà maintenant la parole est à
brigitte simonetta pour savoir le temps
qu'il fera ses prochaines heures
aujourd'hui c'est un temps nuageux
partout mais la couverture nuageuse et
plus ou moins épaisses les nuages sont
plus ou moins actifs selon les régions
regardez la carte pour cet après midi ce
matin il pleuvait sur tout le littoral
atlantique en ce moment la situation se
dégage sur la bretagne mais on peut
craindre encore quelques ondées de
l'aquitaine aux pyrénées petit plus
également sur la corse et à l'est des
alpes à la lorraine partout ailleurs le
ciel restera voilé par les nuages sauf
sur le littoral méditerranéen
on peut parler de véritable ou bhoutan
côté températures elles restent douces
et elle s'inscrit tout à fait dans les
normes saisonnières de 13 à 17 degrés
sur la moitié nord et de 17 à 21 degrés
sur la moitié sud donc douceur et ciel
voilé
ce sera encore valable demain lundi la
situation commencera à se dégrader
franchement mardi le pape jean paul ii
poursuit sa visite en corée du sud hier
il a ordonné 38 prêtre quitte et des
diacres avait auparavant à koungou la
ville qui fut le lieu de grandes
révoltes étudiantes sont claude d'arrigo
non ça n'est pas contre la visite du
pape que ces étudiants manifestent mais
bien contre le gouvernement coréen un
vieux litige dont on sait qu'il s'est
soldé en 1980 par des centaines de morts
à quoi on joue
lire les étudiants et les syndicats ont
décidé pour le moment de suspendre leur
action de revendication par déférence
pour jean paul ii et ce matin durant
soixante dix mille personnes
le pop a procédé à l'ordination de
plusieurs séminaristes coréen
il a également baptisé quelques adultes
tout ceci comme prémices de la grande
cérémonie de canonisation qui aura lieu
demain à séoul
parmi les 103 martyrs coréen
saint-antoine kim un agriculteur de 56
ans décapité pour la fois en 1839
ce vieux couple c'est comme le symbole
du catholicisme coréen d origine un
catholicisme aujourd'hui à l'honneur
puisque sans trois de ces martyrs sont
canonisé par le pape jean paul ii parmi
eux le grand-père de ce grand-père de 84
ans pour les catholiques du monde entier
la gueule de jean kim sera désormais
saint-antoine kim martin ils n'avaient
pas grand chose d'exceptionnel antoine
kim lorsque le premier missionnaire
européen poursuivi par les soldats du
royaume frappe à la porte de sa maison
en 1836 séoul est à une trentaine de
kilomètres et l'église et les nyon
dessert mis à part le paysage elle-même
aujourd'hui antoine kim et sa famille
sont des maraîchers des gens simples
auxquelles les circonstances vont faire
vivre des choses exceptionnelles
il n'ignore pas le danger qu'il ya à
cacher chez eux un prêtre étranger ils
le font simplement parce que c'est leur
devoir de chrétien
quand le père morand a capturé puis
exécutés antoine kim se trouve devant
les juges à son tour de subir la torture
les vexations et la condamnation à mort
au magistrat qui dit aux maraîchers rni
ton christ et tu pourra retrouver les
tiens il répond textuellement une phrase
consignées dans les minutes du procès on
ne trahit pas l'amour pour un autre
amour qu'est-ce que vous éprouvez
lorsqu'on vous dit que vous êtes le
petit fils d'un saint pour moi vous
savez la seule chose qui me préoccupe
c'est d'imiter son courage et de devenir
saint-mont tour
la maison de jean kim la maison qui fut
celle de saint-antoine kim est comme un
lieu de pèlerinage pour tous les
catholiques coréen
le petit groupe des premiers chrétiens
est devenue une foule en 1984 une église
qui grandit un rythme accéléré
l'an dernier nous avons eu 130 3500
baptême il y à plus de 1000 prêtre
coréen
cette année on a ouvert un quatrième
séminaire régional et cette église aussi
ce missionnaire et la conscience d'avoir
beaucoup reçu elle veut maintenant
donner
au salvador deux candidats restent en
lice pour le deuxième tour des élections
présidentielles le démocrate-chrétien
rosset napoléon duarte et le leader de
l'extrême droite le major debuisson
napoléon duarte apparaît comme le favori
du scrutin mais l'atmosphère est très
tendue dans le pays où s'affrontent
l'armée et la guérilla qui récuse
d'ailleurs la représentativité de ces
élections
je voudrais vous faire savoir le
bulletin que nous venons de recevoir à
propos de l'état de santé de monsieur
pierre mauroy il est jugé satisfaisant
et je cite le communiqué du val de grâce
aucun élément ne justifie la publication
d'un nouveau bulletin de santé avant le
9 mai prochain
il faut savoir cultiver notre jardin
voilà ce qu élise et voltaire au siècle
des lumières
même s'ils n'ont pas suivi à la lettre
ce précepte car ces deux lettres qu'il
s'agissait les françaises à 84 sont
devenus de grands jardinier deux sur
trois selon les statistiques et c'est
beaucoup et ça remplit bien les poches
des spécialistes du jardinage qui
affiche un chiffre d'affaires de 17
milliards de francs statistiques et
chiffres qui ont justifié l'intérêt de
frédéric lafont porté à nos jardins à la
foire de paris les tondeuses à gazon ne
touche plus terre
pourtant il faut toujours planté les
salades pouvoir
l'arrosage pas si simple ça s'apprend
jusqu'à mardi soir au salon du jardin on
laisse tomber
attention aux nouvelles techniques qui
pourrait intimider vos voisins
automatique qui permet d'arroser de
fertiliser en douceur alors comment
marche pistolet eh bien voyez vous
introduisez leur gré ici vous enclenchez
et sa route difficile de trouver ici un
râteau ou une bêche priorité au confort
avec le mobilier d'extérieur et les
vérandas l'aspect qu'auraient dujardin a
déjà il a disparu puisque il ya eu la
phase de motorisation c'est à dire mes
outils qu'ils avaient les travaux du
jardin dit difficile
c'est actuellement l'installation au
jardin comme une seconde pièce de la
maison euro s'installent au jardin pour
y vivre confortablement 100 g de terre
suffisent pour connaître toutes les
caractéristiques de votre jardin
l'ordinateur ou donnera la liste des
végétaux compatible avec votre terrain
il y a même un ordinateur qui répondent
aux lettres qu'il y avait un problème de
nutrition et un problème d'insectes
nous l'avons passé à l'ordinateur qui va
donner son diagnostic en même temps le
texte qui apparaît ici est immédiatement
après le passage de ce texte la lettre
va être un pv en ordinateurs et voici la
lettre qui une minute après sort de
cette machine imprimantes
cette rapidité nous permet de traiter
environ deux cents 200 lettres par jour
dit pas c'est qu'il vient de tendre
votre jardin ou à peu près d'une
demi-heure le meilleur par jour le soir
après le travail
or pour vous qu'est ce que c'est que
jardiner une détente des temps qui
ferait du très contraignant non nous
aurons pensez vous landreau est une
satisfaction
je change un petit peu de but jean quoi
et ça vous apporte des joies
ah oui vraiment sculpture légumes puis
sa ville et des fraises enfin disons que
c'est une
c'est un plaisir pour les enfants par la
même occasion quand ils viennent là
bombay ronan le jardin et y sont
satisfait si les curieux même plutôt que
dire bon ben on va lâcher des fresques
c'est vrai les fraises du jardin ont
toujours meilleur goût mais celui des
statuettes qui les côtoient paraît plus
contestable alors on ne va pas parler
détective est mais du jardinage avec
monsieur jacques barrot qui est
professeur au muséum d'histoire
naturelle ça ne nous étonne pas cet
engouement des français ce soir vont pas
du tout vous savez le jardin reste tout
de même l'espace de liberté des espaces
de qualité de qualité dans la diversité
est un espace de beauté en même temps je
crois qu'on ne peut pas parler de jardin
sans parler de paradis il faut faire un
peu d'érudition si vous voulez mais
paradis c'était le vieux beau père cent
du perry daiza qui était un jardin clos
érigé et plein de plantes belle et bonne
paradis qui était d'ailleurs dans la
bible a été créé au sein de l'éden
l'éden dans l'oubli c'était la steppe
désertique flux ce jardin ce jardin bien
entendu représente pour nous aujourd'hui
je crois cette oasis de de beauté et de
liberté au sein de ce désert urbain
souvent qui qui nous entourent mais pas
seulement d'un repli de 7 à phénomène
qui est présent dans toutes nos
campagnes tout aussi bien et ce qui est
frappant c'est que il ne faudrait pas
s'arrêter si vous voulez aux merveilles
technologiques on voit au salon du
jardin il ya aussi tout le savoir des
jardiniers des horticulteurs amateurs
qui est absolument prodigieux pour nous
le jardin est l'intérêt fascinant parce
que c'est en même temps très souvent un
conservatoire de plantes que l'on
croyait disparues ou dont l'usagé tombé
en désuétude alors par exemple est ce
qu'il ya des légumes qui ont disparu je
crois que vous avez vous en faites le
compte en ce moment et vous y êtes
aperçu qu'il y avait un aigu mme que
l'on utilisé dans nos soldats les anges
le jem java site et pas seulement 19e si
vous reprenez des grandes affiches
pédagogiques de l'école primaire qui
éditait agraire des rôles il ya une
affiche sur la soupe qui représente la
composition idéale du pot-au-feu laïque
et républicain eh bien il ya là dedans
tout les légumes et notamment le pané et
bien avait sur le marché maintenant est
haché trouver du panais où il n'était
pas question de faire un pot-au-feu ou
une soupe de légumes sans panex vous ne
trouvez pratiquement plus et pourquoi ça
liestal vous savez il ya eu des
modifications de boujan étaient liés à
des événements historiques
regardez ce qui s'est passé pour le
rutabaga ou pour le topinambour les
périodes mais voilà certains légumes ont
été dix ont frappé un peu de 2d vous
disons de la part du consommateur à la
suite des périodes de restrictions et
des phénomènes de cet ordre et puis
aussi le changement des habitudes
culinaires des habitudes alimentaires en
cuisine peut-être plus autant et c'est
dommage
et vous avez des légumes qui
disparaissent d'ailleurs c'est un
problème du moment un problème grave
nous assistons depuis la guerre et
notamment depuis les cours des vingt
dernières années à une érosion du
patrimoine végétal domestiques de la
france et c'est pour ça que nous avons
un bon laboratoire et avec l'équipe de
recherche cnrs qui travaille commencer
un inventaire systématique ne se
retrouveront dans les jardins eh bien
ces jardins sont des véritables
conservatoires elle nous y retrouvons
des variétés que l'on croyait disparues
et des plantes que des amateurs
passionnés concert les multiplie depuis
des années est-ce que vous même vous
êtes jardinier oui mais malheureusement
vous savez dans mon petit pavillon
bagnolet je me trouve réduit à un tout
petit petit jardin mais j'ai tout de
même une plate-bande où j'aimais herbe
de cuisine et quand même quelques
rosiers et une treille avec red qui de
vigne à la porte de bagnolet oui c'est
pas si mal
or je quitte le jardin des plantes pas
ce que je fais à bt de seigneur quand
même ce jardin des plantes le nom
indique et je retrouve mon tout petit
jardin de bagnolet où je me sens libre
et où je peux tout de même retrouver ce
contact avec la nature
vous savez répond keddou avait cette
belle phrase dans bat la campagne je
crois qu'ils disaient les banlieusards
et la nature au parfois de ces
nostalgies merci beaucoup pour le moment
les italiens font pâle figure au grand
prix de san marin puisqu'ils hier après
la première séance officielle des essais
alboreto le vainqueur du grand prix de
belgique a terminé à la 24e place en ce
moment même se déroule la deuxième
séance d'essais que nous commentons
direct jean mamère et oui en ce moment
vous découvrez sur votre écran la
renault de derek warwick derek warwick
qui hier avait réussi un moins bon temps
que patrick tambay mais qui s'est
racheté un petit peu ce matin lors des
essais libres puisque il a réalisé le
quatrième temps en une 46 700 la
surprise des essais libres de ce matin
elle est venue du petit exploit réalisé
par l'italien andrea de cesaris sur la
voiture française vigie renault qui a
réalisé le meilleur temps devant patrick
tombé sur une renault et michele
alboreto aux italiens
je dire deux essais chronométrés de cet
après-midi et bien qu'ils ont débuté
depuis maintenant environ 12 minutes que
la piste est mouillée il semble pleuvoir
légèrement sur la piste d'imola ce qui
va bien sûr contrarier fortement ces
essais de cet après midi hier déjà la
pluie avait fortement perturbé les temps
qu'on nomme effet les principaux leaders
notamment l'italien michele alboreto que
l'on attend avec impatience ici sur le
circuit après sa victoire de zolder
alors que là c'est jacques laffite
ferait très mal classé depuis hier qui
s'arrête sur le bord de la route et qui
vient d'être doublé ici par derek
warwick dérisoire 8 en vue d'améliorer
son temps et de se rapprocher bien sûr
le plus possible de la pole position
disons pour nous résumer que eh bien les
français jusqu'ici se sont fort bien
comportés ce matin tambay a réalisé le
2e temps des essais libres
warwick sur une voiture française le
quatrième temps arnoux sur ferrari le
cinquième prost sur sa mclaren le 10e
temps seulement il a connu beaucoup
d'ennuis mécaniques philippe alliot sur
sa rame
arte a réalisé le 22e temps jacques
laffite le 24e seulement il aura du mal
à se qualifier ainsi que françois enaud
27e temps que vous découvrez en ce
moment sur votre écran hainaut et le
petit dernier de chez ligier rhône
les essais se termineront maintenant aux
alentours de 14 heures et nous aurons
définitivement la pole position pour le
départ de ce grand prix d'imola le
quatrième grand prix comptant pour le
championnat du monde 1984
au tour de corse et nous parlons
toujours d'automobiles la suprématie de
la toute nouvelle 205 peugeot turbo 16
n'aura pas duré longtemps
le finlandais vatanen a été victime
d'une sortie de route et contraint à
l'abandon ce matin près de calvi dans
une épreuve spéciale la première place
est maintenant occupée par la lancia de
haleine devant r5 turbo du français jean
ragnotti je devrais je voudrais
maintenant vous donner les pronostics de
pires bresse pour le tiercé qui aura
lieu à longchamp demain dimanche 6 mai
dans le prix de graves liés voici donc
ces preneurs ces pronostics qui
s'affiche quel nigaud le huit bras
gallia le 6 pavanner le 11 ou le nez
râble le 5 régal step le 1
tarkan le vin cabot lago le 15
êtes-vous sac le numéro 2 j'espère que
vous avez le temps de noter ses
pronostics de pierrette pour le tiercé
de longchamp demain dans le prix des
gravilliers le moment est donc venu de
retrouver martin alain regnaut pour le
dixième et dernier épisode de son
feuilleton intitulé les dix jours pour
la forme
nous la retrouvons chez elle en direct
et du touquet pour nous parler de la
thalassothérapie
ces systèmes de cure qui est tellement à
la mode aujourd'hui martin a que des
gouttes
oui noël s'il est encore un peu plus au
nord en temps normal mais je peux vous
dire qu'ici il fait un beau soleil et
que tout va bien dans ce plat pays
alors nous sommes ici dans un endroit où
l'on fait de la remise en forme et où on
peut au fil des jours un peu récupéré
tout jaillir tous les conseils que nous
avons donné depuis quelques jours aux
téléspectateurs alors je voudrais vous
montrer qu'il n'ya pas qu'eux au touquet
tout de suite qu'on peut faire des cuirs
la france est un pays de cure et si vous
regardez bien toutes les petites flèches
qui sont ici nous sommes le plus au nord
dans le pays bien entendu le plus
vivifiant le mien mais si vous descendez
le long des côtes vous vous apercevez
que toute la bretagne possède des
centres de thalassothérapie roscoff le
plus ancien puits nous descendons vers
l'atlantique nous en trouvons un certain
nombre jusqu'à biarritz et puis sur la
côte méditerranéenne
aussi nous avons des centres de
thalassothérapie avec le plus extrême
ici à villeneuve loubet nous saluons le
dernier-né qui est cap d'agde mais
jérôme camille qui est avec moi va vous
dire qu'il n'y a pas de cure que sur le
bord de la mer mais aussi à l'intérieur
des terres c'est visible à l'oeil nu ce
sont ces petits points noirs que l'on
voit la exergue marquis qui a
pratiquement des zones à l'intérieur de
la france où où il ya énormément station
thermale
il y en a à peu près une centaine ce qui
n'est pas possible de les citer toutes
mais j'aurais vous citez vittel
contrexéville vichy etc smeba
eugénie-les-bains saint-amand-les-eaux
et puis tant d'autres vous dire aussi
que vichy plombières date de l'époque
romaine à dire qu'elles ont deux mille
ans d'âge et c'est assez c'est quand
même c'est assez impressionnant alors on
va ajouter la corse pour faire plaisir à
jérôme kamini je suis du nord il est de
corse il ya aussi quatre stations encore
ceci pour vous dire noël que ces cures
de formes sont destinés à accueillir ce
que ce qu'on appelle les fatiguer du
monde moderne
ils ne sont pas vraiment malade ils ne
se sentent plus très bien alors vous
avez entendu les publicités passeport
pour la forme pour la ligne profité pour
voir de l'eau éliminé vitalité et la
lutte anti stress revitalisation
antitabac occasion de découvrir le sport
bien des choses
jérôme camille et bernard ronfler était
d'hier ici même
ils vont nous proposer maintenant de
regarder comment dans une cure marine on
se remet en forme
alors voilà où ce qui est très frappant
d'andorre dans ces protestations de
thalassothérapie c'est que les gens se
promènent plusieurs en peignoir avec un
petit côté 1928 1930 ils se parlent
entre eux ils discutent entre eux et
regardaient bizarre car il ya devant
nous 30 km de plage
et puis tout
de toute cure commence par une une
rencontre avec son médecin
un petit bilan de santé très rapide
c'est pas très important mais pour même
le faire et la clé ré personnalisé
j'imagine totalement totalement
personnalisés on prend ça tensions vont
un petit peu son état physique général
les kilos trop 10 ans leur ouïe pour
dialoguer mais ça nous concerne ce que
ça comporte
le quart des coeurs bien sûr et puis là
voilà tout le monde se dirige avec un
programme voile avec un programme il a
sa petite fiche dans sa poche alors bas
fonctionnel c'est quoi alors les bains
fonctionnel sous gestion de bain qui
permettent une relaxation du corps qui
permettent aussi à tous les systèmes
en tout le système musculaire de se
relaxer c'est très agréable
c'est une décontraction totale les gens
ils prennent beaucoup de plaisir
en fait on s'occupe de son corps c'est
agréable comme tout alors là on refera
un doux alors là bas voir on va on va
aller leur part on remarque romain et on
va vers les bains bouillonnants
là aussi c'est une décontraction c'est
l'activation circulatoire libye lancée
car voilà beaucoup de buts beaucoup
désagréable qui peut l'être les ports
partir alors la détente complète une
impression de bien-être en test
et puis voilà onze ans maintenant
alors il faut se motiver pour dire qu'il
y à des soins qu'ils ne feraient pas les
boues ya de la peur puis l'indispensable
relation avec les kinés
hommage qui vous détend et qui
accompagne le malade voilà et le malade
continue continue sa petite promenade le
long de cette espèce de course alors là
ça va être très intéressant et
sur le jet on avait fait fort en jette à
l'eau chaude l'eau de mer bien ces
merdes le quart d'heure où c'est à l'eau
de mer ici et puis dans un jeu que l'on
peut régler je fais également le droit
de demander un gel douche je préfère à
personne quand même un garçon un peu
écartée mais séparément quand il ya des
moments où on demande aussi un petit jet
d'eau chaude pour pollution pour lui
demander plus à l'aise dans l'axé
on est plutôt dans le curé l'anglais
s'est calmement très grave
et puis il ya aussi des questions
henri froide et l'a dit la dame ne sent
pas très à l'aise
et puis il ya aussi donc ces séances
d'aérosols c'est le curiste respire des
particules taux qui pénètrent dans les
poumons et dans le sang et ça aussi
c'est une façon de se sentir mieux dans
son corps totalement son corps
mais ce qui est très frappant quand on
se promène dans ce centre c'est de voir
que des relations sans gaz que le salon
se parlent entre eux soit on discute le
sport
pas seulement la plus mauvais temps
puisqu'il peut être êtes vous
aujourd'hui
ok et on se parle d'eux
ceux ci s'affairent
et puis voilà la relaxation car c'est
vrai on a envie d'être bien dans son
corps on se redécouvre et on se
redécouvre sur des 16 banques on se
détend totalement oublie tout à fait
l'avis qu'on a vécu et puis alors voilà
les dernières
en revanche ces images de la piscine
alimenté à l'autre mais revient
extrêmement est une ruine
mais à 37 degrés et ce sont vraiment des
images de bonheur on sent plus léger
là-dedans d'oujda dans les bayonnaises
complètement à sunrise l'image de cette
jeune femme
keller très heureux
tu as fait sereine
il ya six majeur cependant les images
que nous avons vues hier tout au long de
la journée avec des ambiances très très
agréable ambiance très douce très soft
comme le dire aujourd'hui
et ce sont ces images
la piscine qui a l'air du bizspark
un peu suédoise très belle alors noël je
suis maintenant avec monsieur coudry le
directeur de cet établissement
mais auparavant je voudrais insister sur
le fait que nous avons dû en choisir un
parmi beaucoup et que la france entière
peut accueillir des curistes
alors je rappelle qu'il existe par dont
un guide de la thalassothérapie ainsi
qu'un guide du thermalisme et je vous
propose d'avoir immédiatement deux
adresses l'union des établissements de
thalassothérapie 52 rue de la tour
d'auvergne paris 9e et la fédération
terrienne laissez-le s'inscrire un peu
sur l'écran pour les personnes qui sont
à terrifier qu'il tombe le noter tout de
même écrit alors je laisse ça c'est la
tour d'auvergne ou venez de le dire est
votre deuxième adresse fédération
thermale et climatique française 16 rue
de l'estrapadé paris 5e qu'est ce que ça
coûte cher de les faire de la
thalassothérapie ajouté on va parler
dans quelques instants mais pour
l'instant notre caméra est en train de
vous faire découvrir les beautés
j'imagine
nous allons voir maintenant les menus
qui sont préparés pour les curistes
alors vous voyez ici des crevettes puis
terrine de poisson pourquoi vous
demanderez à cette heure là vous allez
nous donner feu et parce que nous sommes
accompagnés de jean qui maintenant sont
à table
haddock rue saint-jacques algues au
vinaigre la basse pierre qui pousse dans
la région qu'elle est bonne ça jacques
langoustines artichauts nature alors
soviétique donnant tendue au fromage 0%
à 7 candy nav of de linping en sont la
plus lourde mais encore très peu
calorique tourte aux crustacés terrine
de jambon maigre crudités sans
vinaigrette dessert fruits fraises
melons kiwi etc
ça fait rêver comme d'autres trop d'eau
un steak frites à la cantine alors ceci
pour dire monsieur coutry que l'on peut
bien manger manger santé sans chant
grossir et même parfois amaigrissantes
absolument ce restaurant est un
restaurant santé n'est pas un restaurant
véritablement diététique destinée à
faire perdre du poids d'une manière
spectaculaire
il est beaucoup plus destiné à permettre
que les curistes fasse une pause dans
leur alimentation habituelle si vous
leur laisser la possibilité de se
prendre en charge en mangeant bien
absolument on impose absolument pas le
l'utilisation de ce restaurant santé
les gens peuvent librement choisir leur
mode de nutrition dans les différents
restaurants de la station et des deux
hôtels à coller à la sculpture alors un
petit mot qui sont vos clients
on va pas parler en âge moyen on va je
vais vous donner de pourcentage
56 % de nos curistes ont moins de 50 ans
et 84 % de nos curistes ont moins de 60
ans et alors ils viennent pour quelles
raisons la doc est fatigué par la vie
urbaine de raison de raison essentielle
les établissements de thalassothérapie
traite en priorité
si vous voulez tous les problèmes
rhumatismaux et soigne les maladies de
dites de civilisation c'est à dire le
stress une grande fatigue générale
alors tout de suite une question à le
noël la pause et tout à l'heure ceci
coûte cher ceux ci coûtent selon les
endroits au touquet par exemple cela
coûte actuellement 250 francs par jour
oui mais sans un tel sens le restaurant
c'est à dire les choses proprement
uniquement la partie de thalassothérapie
alors noël je voudrais vous dire qu'il
existe un véritable problème avec la
sécurité sociale et nous ne pouvons que
la bordée ici nous y reviendrons
certainement par la suite car la
sécurité sociale rembourse très mal les
cures en même temps les rembourse qui
est une preuve de garanties médicales et
je crois qu'actuellement les centres de
thalassothérapie pour ces personnes qui
ne sont ni malade ni bien portante sont
en discussion sur un forfait de
thalassothérapie mais comme il s'agit
que de discussions
nous y reviendrons simplement plus tard
viendra je voudrais pas me la passer la
parole à jérôme une seconde car il est
accompagné de curistes nous avons eu le
point de vue du directeur de
l'établissement reste entendre les
curistes tous deux vivent ça ne
suffisait pas d'avoir le point de vue du
directeur d'établissement alors nous
avons là deux couples lyon en moyenne
d'âge quoi 35-40 sarlat dites moi la
raison pour laquelle vous êtes de nuit
c'est pour une remise en forme et vous
vous sentez comment savez combien de
jours vous êtes là une semaine et vous
un des commandites bras
et bien c'est très très relax et très
est-ce que ça suffit une semaine je
pense que c'est bien si on n'a pas de
problème de santé pour des problèmes de
santé c'est peut-être des vacances au
décès des vacances oui mais des vacances
un petit peu active d'une certaine façon
vite moi c'est une prise de conscience
ou une envie passagère c'est la première
fois que vous venez là oui c'est la
première fois que je dis est en cure
mais enfin je suis comme beaucoup de
gens qui travaillent beaucoup et je
crois que nous sommes des lions j'ai
besoin de décompresser de temps en temps
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
venu en thalasso dois dire que j'avais
entendu beaucoup de choses sur la
thalassothérapie est tellement des loges
j'étais un petit peu inquiet quant à la
réalité des choses et puis finalement je
le dois avouer que c'est proprement
miraculés ont fait en tout cas en ce qui
me concerne
vous étiez commun d'arrivants fatigués
surtout fatigué par la vie parisienne
pas de problème à la de maladies
particulier mais je crois puis si c'est
surtout un investissement la santé et
finalement notre capitale et ont fait
aussi un investissement parce que à
travers les dires de nombreux curistes
c'est un effet qui se prolonge donc le
bien-être que l'on ressent actuellement
est un bien-être immédiat mais je pense
que d'ici deux ou trois mois on
continuera à avoir une vitalité beaucoup
bien meilleur dans de meilleures
conditions en rentrant dans la période
du revenant la région urbaine audio figé
rome je pense que vous allez tomber j'ai
de rendre l'antenne on aurait écouté
volontiers plus longtemps ses curistes
ses usagers qui nous parlait de la
thalassothérapie et je pense que là on
n'a plus le temps un martin écoutez si
vous nous laissez une minute on pourrait
vous récapitule à ce qui se passe ici
qui est un peu a résumé des dix jours à
ce qu'on a le temps car nous n'avons pas
le temps c'est la raison pour laquelle
je vous demande de bien vouloir
interrompre ce direct depuis le touquet
après avoir considéré les avantages les
bienfaits de la thalassothérapie
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir n'est ce
pas martin sur le bilan sûrement
sûrement sûrement en tout cas de
week-end au touquet si vous y rester non
je rentrais bien alors vous allez
rejoindre les tracas de la vie
parisienne où vous aurez besoin un jour
ou l'autre de thalassothérapie comme les
autres
jean pierre vincent le nouvel
administrateur de la comédie-française
boucle sa première saison avec le
suicide et c'est une comédie soviétique
écrite en 1928 par nicolaï erdman
contrairement à ce que son titre
pourrait indiquer cette pièce déclenche
souvent le rire des spectateurs parce
qu'elle présente des situations à la
limite du burlesque
aussi parce qu elles taillent en pièces
un certain type de société et de
relations entre les hommes
c'est une pièce d'actualité alors avant
de retrouver françois chaumette l'un des
interprètes du suicide et nous allons
vous proposer un extrait où l'on voit
michel aumont à membres de
l'intelligentsia soviétique venir
proposer à simon le suicidant alain
pralon de mourir pour lui et pour sa
cause séoul accusé personne au contraire
il faut accuser il faut dénoncer
vous vous suicidez parfait rien à dire
suicidez vous à votre santé mais
suicidez vous en tant que membre
responsable de la collectivité
ne perdez pas de vue que vous n'êtes pas
seul au mans citoyens poggi khalikov
regardez autour de vous
qu'est ce que vous voyez considérer
notre intelligentsia vous voyez quoi
beaucoup de choses qu'est ce que vous
entendez rien du tout pourquoi est-ce
que vous n'entendez rien parce que ce
tête
pourquoi est-ce que c'était par son la
force de ce taire et à mort on ne peut
pas le forcer de se taire citoyens pause
et cathy kopp
si le mort veut bien parler par les
temps qui courent ce qu'un vivant peut
penser ce la mort peut le dire je suis
venu vous voir en tant que moore
citoyens j'écris comme je suis venu vous
voir de la part de l'intelligentsia
russe tout entière
très heureux de faire votre connaissance
asseyez vous s'il vous plaît pour prenez
congé de la ville citoyens peu technique
offre en quoi vous avez raison en effet
on ne peut pas vivre il faut bien que ce
soit la faute de quelqu'un si moi je ne
peux pas en témoigner vous citoyen
polygamie comme vous le pouvez vous
n'avez plus rien à perdre
plus rien à craindre vous êtes libres
maintenant voilà alors quand ce show met
vous vous interpréter un voisin mon
voisin un peu filou de ce simon camden
suicide et que tout le monde intéresse
oui c'est à dire que je suis le premier
alerté par les bouses de poser kalmikoff
le premier alerté parce que elle a cru
comprendre au cours d'une scène de
ménage qui se déroule la nuit et alors
qu'il lui a réclamé à manger au milieu
de la nuit l'a cru comprendre qu'il
était dans un état de stress comme
disait le monsieur tout à l'heure dans
un état désespéré
et elle cherche un appui auprès de son
voisin qui est qu'à la bouche keane qui
est un fort inquiets
le propriétaire du stand de tir et et du
mesureur de force et elle lit il faut
faire quelque chose pour lui et comme ce
voisin est un petit peu filou comme vous
dites
à partir du moment où il croire
comprendre la détermination de suicide
de peser khalikov il va alerter tous les
individus qui entoure la maison et le
redis posé calme comme va se suicider
pour rien et à partir de ce moment là
c'est la scène que vous venez de voir
tous les toutes les forces tous les
individus se déchaînent église mais si
vous vous suicider au moins celui-ci
dévouent pour quelque chose
et celui-ci les vous pour moi enfin je
me disais boris vian si tu veux être
écoutés être salem on recommence par
mourir le feu
mais ce qui est très étonnant c'est que
cette pièce qui a été créé en russie
soviétique mais très peu joué se trouve
jouait aussi à paris 50 ans après par
deux troupes dont celle de la comédie
française qu'elle voyage une pièce qui
n'a pas été jouer qu'ils aient joué
cinquante ans après c'est à dire que on
savait que la pièce existait
une des premières pièces des rendements
de la première baisse des demandes qui
s'appelait le monde avait eu un succès
considérable en union soviétique et
lorsque meyerhold et je crois
stanislavski s'était intéressé à la
production de hermann ils avaient tous
les deux voulu monter sa prochaine pièce
et à demain a commencé à écrire le
suicidé et pour des raisons pour des
raisons assez obscures meyerhold est
allé jusqu'à la couturière du spectacle
laquelle couturière n'a pas eu un
retentissement suffisant pour les
encourager à continuer malgré les
menaces d'interdiction avait et la pièce
est tombée dans l'oubli erdmann par la
suite a écrit beaucoup de scénarios a
écrit des dialogues de dessins animés à
a vécu jusqu'en 70 en union soviétique
de façon de façon presque normale et
cette pièce s'est retrouvé s'est
retrouvé en italie je crois que ce sont
les italiens les premiers qui ont eu
envie de voir cette pièce et depuis elle
commençait à voir ce succès françois
chaumette nous vous remercions je
rappelle le titre de cette pièce
d'hermann le suicide et qui se joue au
théâtre national de l'odéon
je voudrais vous rappeler les titres de
l'actualité de ce samedi matin donc il y
a des chances qu'un règlement se
produisent au liban pour la constitution
et le fonctionnement d'un gouvernement
puisque monsieur nabih berri pour être
accepté les propositions qui ont été
faites et à propos de de la route un
accident terrible ce matin qui dans un
autocar qui a provoqué la mort de six
personnes et fait plus d'une trentaine
de blessés
voilà l'essentiel de l'actualité
prochain rendez-vous de la rédaction à
20h christine autres un thé vert 23
heures hervé claude pour l'édition de la
nuit nous on se retrouve demain à 12h45
au revoir bon après midi